hi there i'm very happy to be part of
pycon and by data conference berlin
i want to thank all of you who joined i
hope this will be a useful and
interesting time
today we're going to discuss detecting
drift we're gonna tackle the question
how to evaluate and explore data
drifting machine learning systems
my name is emmy john i am co-founder at
cto of evidently ai
and evidently we build an open source
tool to evaluate test and monitor
machine learning's models in production
prior to evidently i helped industrial
companies to build and deploy machine
learning based services in production so
the experience again over this time is
influences the way how we build this
tool and evidently
so everybody knows that building a
successful machine learning based
service is pretty hard task by itself
because we have to run a bunch of
experiments then develop the service and
then deploy it in production but
unfortunately the job hasn't stopped
there because model starts to interact
with the real world environment this
environment is often unstable and this
time model's quality tends to decrease
when model operates in production each
way failure can cause something because
well it's already influenced the
business or technological process so we
had to do something with that and the
standard answer is monitoring basically
when we monitor machine learning models
we either
measure model quality or error and it's
even better when we understand how
exactly model interact with the business
process in this case you can also
monitor things like product metrics like
purchases speaks views etc
but it's not always enough and i'm going
to drop a couple of examples where we
cannot just rely on standard machine
learning monitoring which is quite nice
for a lot of cases but not all
uh pretty often we deal with some
forecasting services for example demand
forecast for some products or services
and here we can have a solid horizon of
our predictions it can be weeks it can
be months and here we just cannot rely
on the standard performance monitoring
because
for calculating some quality metrics we
need to wait for this weeks or months in
order to get our feedback or ground
choose to calculate the metrics so this
is the first example
the second is the volatile target
function which you're trying to estimate
is help of machine learning in this case
where when function is tend to change
its values very often it's hard to miss
the moment when the quality starts
decreasing because just the function is
very volatile
when you deal with
the big amounts of objects
and they have different object segments
for example different segments of users
um
it can be as well a problem because well
if you work with regression problem
model can underestimate the target
function on some segments it can
overestimate the targets on another
segments and when we aggregate the
quality these heroes can our compensate
one another
one can say okay you can just analyze
the model's quality separately on
different segments and this is true
but became a bit complicated when you
have like really a lot of segments like
dance or 50s or more
and the last example i want to bring
here is the cases where we have a delay
before we get the feedback or ground
truth but this delay is not that high
for example it can be just hours or days
and in this case you can just rely on
the past quality in order to monitor the
model's performance and sometimes it's
enough but sometimes not because you can
just miss the moment when the quality
drops so what can we do
and the answer is let's take data we
have it hands now and try to calculate
something and let's call it early
monitoring
there are basically several things which
you can calculate when you have only
input data and probably models output
this is data quality data drift and
output drift
let's discuss them in more details
so data quality is something that i
would say we need to measure almost
always because in most cases when
something is wrong with the model that's
because input data is wrong
and even if you do not have any
reference data which you can use
as the basis for comparison uh to our
current data we can still calculate
something for example we can always
calculate statistics like share of
missing values share of constant
features we can explore correlations
between pairs of features and
correlations between features and models
output because we want to for example
have only features in our data set which
correlates
correlates between each other
less than some specific values or we can
prefer to keep correlations between
models output and features under some
thresholds right we can also measure the
ranges for each features and we can come
up on some expectations just based on
our domain knowledge or future concepts
like uh prefer to have non-negative age
negative salaries and things like this
so there are a lot of things you can
calculate even not having reference data
when you have reference data it's much
easier because because we can compare
right so
we can take the data from the training
stage or we can use the previous model
batch
and we can compare our current data with
this reference data
so here we can easily compare
distributions
and other statistics
for example some descriptive statistics
like means medians quantiles min max
between features
from reference and current right and
here there are basically two ways how we
can do that first is simple let's say
point by systemation where you can
calculate for example a median on top of
reference data set then imagine for the
same feature on current data and then
you just calculate difference and that's
it you can then set up some threshold on
this difference and alert when it's too
high for example but everybody knows
that this is not robust enough uh let's
say because if you have some um
outliers or the sample sizes are
different then these statistics can um
be
quite different right but maybe four
mediums it's not that
correct because mediums are pretty
stable right but for means
and other statistics it is and in this
case you can use some interval
estimation for example with help of some
statistical tests or other statistical
procedure calculate the confidence
intervals for your descriptive
statistics and compare uh them into uh
on base basis
on top of these intervals right so we
compare not just
uh means but integral around it and
set some alarms on top of this
information
um evidently you have a prebuilt
dashboard that helps you to analyze data
quality and if you have reference and
current or just current data you can
easily create the evidently dashboard
either an either interactive one or in
json format and see a lot of descriptor
statistics or results of comparison and
see whether the data quality is good
enough
uh together with data quality you can
measure more complicated things like
day-to-day which is basically a
comparison between feature distribution
data drift can um be with and without
performance decay right but sometimes if
very important features are drifting and
there is no like very logical
explanations of why this can be an issue
and the signal of the early
early signal of the potential problems
let's say so uh there are several
important things that we should take
into account when you calculate such
drifts like which exact statistical
tests we use what are the reasonable uh
confidence for the drift detection and
what are alert conditions and we're
going to discuss it but um before we are
going into this discussion i just want
to say that all this works for models
output as well so we can calculate not
only a drift for input features but also
drift for models output which is quite
nice because if you have results of the
previous models run on previous batches
of data right you can compare the
model's output on the current
batch of data with the previous one and
come up with some conclusions which are
very nice
and yeah now the question how exactly do
we define that data has drifted so well
you need to uh choose specifical test uh
come up with the confidence level and
then set up some thresholds uh for our
alarms and there are a lot of different
approach uh how you can measure data
just
let's say that the standard one is using
statistical tests
and here you can go for parametric tests
or non-parametric tests
it evidently we built and use both
approach and there are some
considerations on which approach to
choose
so i believe parametric tests are very
nice when you have some subset of golden
features i mean key performance uh which
you like know right and you know the
means and you can come up with some
expectations on the future distributions
and some uh parameters of these
distributions like mean values
mean distribution value standard
situation and things like that
so um if you have only one sample you
can generate these expectations for
example you want the
age feature being normally distributed
around like 25 years or things like this
it's just an example and in this case if
you can come up with some expectations
you can use one sample test like z test
or more often t test and compare the um
observed mean with the expected one or
for binary features you can use one
proportion of the tests so
a lot of things like this
if you have two distributions mainly you
have reference data it became even
easier because you can use two
proportional two samples test like two
proportions that test for binary
features or two sample t test for means
things like this
so uh the advantages of the parametric
tests are that they are more sensitive
which means that you can detect drift
earlier if you have some parametric
tests
but there are some disadvantages which
are
first is that these parametric tests are
more demanding because well we need to
um have the data which have some
specific distributions right and we need
to like
choose and consume the test for each
individual features which is time
consuming well and if you have really a
lot of features probably you don't want
to like select specific tests for each
features but if you have like small
amount of very important ones why not to
do that
and an alternative approach is using
non-parametric tests
these non-parametric tests are much less
demanding right so you can probably
select the non-parametric tests based on
just
um
feature type i mean numerical
categorical binary
and some
sample configurations like sample size
for categorical features it makes sense
to
make sure that for each category you
have not less than
let's say five values for each bucket
for key square tests so there are
actually some limitations but there are
not that strict as in parametric tests
right so probably here you can just
easily optimize the select of each
specific test for each feature right and
go for uh this automated um
estimations
for example you can set the coma guru
smirnoff test for all of numerical
features or maybe a case sample anderson
test if you prefer to get more sensitive
uh to have more sensitive procedure for
diff detection and for categorical
features you can use for example pearson
key square test and if you have like
very small data set maybe um think about
some exact tests but for very small
samples in most cases when we apply
machine learning model in production we
have big enough case
samples to uh use
other tests but why not to consider that
and actually to add to it i believe um
you shouldn't limit your estimation only
for statistical tests in some senses you
can
perfectly use any procedure to compare
distributions and some distances like
western stand distance is the perfect
example of such evaluation procedure so
you can use distances between
probability distributions you can use
some indexes it's all work very well
so the only consideration here is these
non-parametric tests are in most cases
less sensitive to drift comparing to
parametric tests which means probably
will detect this drift a bit later
but it's easier to apply and it's much
easier to choose between different tests
so it evidently as i said before we use
both parametric and non-parametric tests
we use distances we use indexes and
moreover evidently can automatically
select the right statistical test for
each of your feature so if you want to
quickly get the dashboard with the
information about data gifts values
distances between your features you can
just collect the reference and current
data
said uh give this pass this data to
evidently and get the dashboard in html
or json format to explore the gist so
it's open source and why not to try if
you're interested in just
there are more
questions i want to tackle uh
considering data gist estimation and
first is large data sets
in most cases when we deal with large
datasets we can
get oversensitive results so we always
can find some places where our features
are different and the statistics will
often said that here is a drift and here
i want to make one node
initially the statistics was made to
work with samples right not with the
whole general population because if you
have the whole population you can just
directly measure whatever you want right
and for machine learning it's pretty
important for duration because it
doesn't make a lot of sense to
um
like apply your statistical tests for
like hundreds and thousands
of objects it makes sense to go for a
more practical solution and either do
something or packaging so something help
us to
select some subsamples from our
reference and current data and apply
statistical tests to these subsamples
if you have a lot of data the random
sampling strategy will work perfectly in
this case
uh but if you have let's say
um
non-balanced classification problem then
it makes sense to explore explore other
sampling strategies like uh
certification right and in this case you
have just better samples
and alternative to sampling solution is
marketing here you just split your data
into some buckets then you calculate the
statistics individually for each buckets
for example mean future value and then
you compare means uh using statistical
tests in other words you aggregate some
uh value over your buckets and then you
compare this aggregated value between
each other and by doing this you reduce
the data size
the advantage is that you do not need to
i think over the
um right sampling strategy but downside
is that it's uh maybe even potentially
heavier and you still need to like come
up with the amount of buckets right so
whether you use 20 or 30 or 100 but if
you have historical data you can
experiment on top of that and find the
optimal
amounts of buckets and other parameters
of your calculation procedure so
historical data always helps to like
decrease
the
amount of um uncertainty and
come up this right variation procedure
the second question i want to tackle
here is non-batch models because for
batch models it's pretty straightforward
you just always have bikes which are
like data samples and you can compare
distributions between different batches
but when it comes to a continuous data
stream it's hard to like compare
something and here i suggest to pick
some window function uh and
generate samples by this windows
the questions here are that uh what are
the size of this window functions what
are the step right for moving this
feature but again if you have historical
data you can experiment over there and
then decide whether you have uh the
window function
with the window size equal to one hour
or equal to one day it just depends on
the case and the data you have
and finally how to like specify all the
tests and metrics and thresholds for
alerts there are basically two
strategies the first one is go with
defaults in this case you can just
picks the tests on based on the uh
feature values right and for example
start your monitoring using tools like
evidently when you where you have
everything like predefined start
monitoring and then uh based on the
alarms uh like false dollars and the
right alarms are just some parameters
like um for example adjust some
thresholds for different features uh and
maybe for models output
this is the option one and i really
suggest to go for this option if you
need to set up monitoring earlier and
start monitoring what has happened with
your production model
the sub option is a bit more complicated
but if you have some historical data and
some time resources
i would go for that option
here the idea is to use your historical
data to specify all the suitable tests
and drift conditions so what you can do
here is for example
um select the amount uh the moment in
time where you have no gist
define the candidates test and apply
them
all the time
then you can pick the most sensitive uh
test
mainly it is the lowest p value but one
that still does not detect drift so this
test works well because there is no
drift and it do not detect that but it's
very sensitive and if the data will
differ a bit much it will uh say that
this is the database here and then uh
you can it's even better if you have a
period in time from your historical data
where you have drift because you can
test your selected statistical test
against this gist and make sure that it
detects
uh this moment or you can like create
some uh synthetic data use the drift and
see whether your test works or not and
then uh when you did some when you do
some after you do some experiments you
can just reuse this architecture for
your production data so again a bit more
complicated but
you will
specify and adapt your test to your
specific model based on the historical
data
and finally i want to mention some
nuances into the drift interpretation
because as i said before data gift and
prediction gist are not always good it's
highly depend on the context and here
are two examples
let's say we detected data gift and
non-detecting prediction risk
it can be positive interpretation
because if you detected drift
like for
non-important features so important
features did not drifted and model is
robust enough so model's output did not
drifted then probably there is no need
to intervene and model can
survive it
it can be vice versa for example this
drift which were detected were detected
on top of very important features and
probably model shred should have reacted
on that because something important has
changed but model did not which means
that model probably does not extrapolate
that well in this case it makes sense to
um
do some adhoc analysis and intervene
unless you're also right if you detected
both database and
prediction gift one can say this is the
definitely problem but it might be and
might not let's say our important
features has changed
uh has changed and uh model's output
elsa has changed but it has changed in
very like predictable and logical way
for example the prices go down and
models started to predict higher sales
so probably a model extrapolate price
well and there is no need to intervene
model can survive that but the negative
scenario is that our important features
changed model behavior is
uh unreasonably changed and in this case
it makes sense to enter in an abundance
top model for sources like further
analysis
finally
what we do if you have some
issues and alerts in our early
monitoring
so first will be fix all the data
quality issues because when the input
data
is changed or corrupted then
almost definitely you'll have some
problem with machine learning models
right so first
run data quality and fix all the issues
with data quality and integrity
then if you see some prediction and data
just
as we just discussed before it highly
depends on the context right it can be a
problem it cannot be problem and here i
suggest to
go for some
uh
more complicated interpretation um which
takes into account the context around of
this drift and direction can be from
something uh pretty
straightforward like just retraining the
model on top of
new batch of data and continue to apply
that to something more complicated like
uh calibrating or rebuilding model uh
totally like experimenting with
different algorithms and approach or
even changing business logic on top of
the
model's outputs like maybe using some
higher decision threshold maybe exclude
certain segments from the analysis and
send some objects to manual review maybe
using some fallback system which is not
uh rely on machine learning models but
more robust and rely on some rule-based
systems so there are a lot of things
that you can do but um anyway it makes
sense to first detect that something has
changed this is why early monitoring
makes a lot of sense for production
systems
so this is all i wanted to share with
you today i want to thank you for your
time and your attention and i'm happy to
discuss
anything related to early monitoring and
answer any of your questions
thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you so much emily
now welcome live here
so we have some questions from the
audience um
i'm gonna check them here
the first one is
with too many input tests there will be
many false positives due to noise or
poorly defined thresholds which can lead
to alarm hell how to prevent that
hi there and thank you so much for a
very
important question yes i personally uh
saw such cases and it's really important
to like set up the
let's say the rule of how you're going
to
send alarms and operate on top of uh
these um
messages about drift so i suggest to use
different threshold and test with
different sensitivity for different
features and for example like use
maybe
higher thresholds for um
more important features right so to
avoid this uh fast alerts and second is
um maybe uh play around with some
sampling strategy
and um for uh decreasing uh this
institute of tests use uh the smaller
samples where you like selected uh the
objects uh
maybe randomly um
yeah randomly for bigger data sets is
enough so um the main idea is to play
with the uh parameters of your drift
detection systems uh select specific
test select the way how you generate the
sample and maybe have
different thresholds for different
features based on the importance
thank you very much
the next question is do you count change
of standard deviation as drift do you
have tests for that
uh currently
no and evidently it's not implemented
but what you definitely have is the way
how you can use the custom python
function as the
data drift
metric let's say that we can implement a
python function that's taken to as an
input to um the data frame series i mean
pandas data frame and returns a
numerical value and uh if you're
interested in comparing standard
deviations it can be
the implementation of such tests but out
of the box unfortunately we don't have
that maybe it's a good idea to add thank
you so much for this question
thanks
does evidently plan to integrate with
established monitoring system such as
grafana or datadog
um well let's
again a very nice question and we are
now in the process of considering
different integration options right now
we have just an example of such
integration so we just manually like
created the grafana dashboard for data
drift and couple of more like
uh dashboards data gift model
performance and things like that and we
showed it to our users to like get
information what they think uh there are
quite a lot of people who really like it
so
now this is for us a good signal to
start uh work in this direction so right
now we have an example uh which is
easily customizable for different
machine learning models
and later this year i believe it will be
like
better
integration interesting
so next question is how is your
architecture set up do you store the
original metrics each mean of column in
a bucket or load it from there
right now we um
yeah
good question so uh right now i have
different uh analyzers so this is like
code modules uh which uh makes the
calculations and one of such of these
analyzers are
is data quality and in data quality yes
we store things like amounts of columns
and rows and column names uh all the
descriptive um
all the descriptions of the data right
uh but uh when it comes to monitoring
and for example those uh
integration with grafana i mean i mean
the example we do not pass this data to
primitives and we do not uh have any
dashboards in grafana related to this uh
just descriptive information
so uh
we have different um
types of reports in evidently it's
dashboards html and we have also
json profiles and in json profiles we
store all this information so we do not
read it from anywhere we just uh read it
from the data and um we read config if
something is useful written in config we
also can copy it in profile
so like hope this answer the question
great yeah um one last question for for
the time being
instead of asking has significant drift
occurred what a more central question be
has drifter card that impact the
usefulness of the model
uh
yes i think it makes a lot of sense
actually and we really thinking about
moving to this direction uh technically
it's a bit more complicated because for
this analysis you only need to have like
data um about your features and maybe
models output and target but uh if you
want to really like see how much drift
or just any changes in good data
impact your model it makes sense to have
an access to model to like play around
with such uh changes and features and
see how the model's output changes and
whether it's really affect
your business process it's even better
when you can play around with these such
things but it um
definitely takes more complicated
integration and then access to the model
this is uh like the main reason why we
now limit our calculations only to the
detection of drift but that's very wise
question to like explore more whether
this drift really corrupts something or
not
great thank you very much and let's
thank all emily again for the great talk
thank you
thank you so much it was pleasure
[Applause]